messy is fun okay
my whole life is a giant mess and I love
it I know what things are you're like an
angel with no wings so like a person
everything hurts
running is impossible Oh windows are the
eyes to the house anything is a toy if
you play with it I have no idea what I'm
doing but I know I'm doing it really
really well nailed it are you crying no
I'm not crying okay a little lerczak to
jerks oh butter is my favorite food I'm
allergic to sushi every time I eat more
than 80 sushis that barf
I'm fine it's just that life is
pointless and nothing matters and I'm
always tired also I can't sleep I'm
overeating then the world hobbies
interests me oh babe hang on you're here
I got so bored I started thinking about
existence do i matter do any of us is
there a master plan and it works a grand
design just dumb stuff like that if you
rearrange layers of Peru you could spell
Europe I definitely have more Lions than
any other country in the whole world
right now there's an old saying show
business the show must go wrong when
life gives you lemons make lemonade I
read that one so I can eliminate it I
like to think that it applies to life I
tried to make ramen in the coffee pot
and I broke everything just remember
every time you look up at the moon I too
will be looking at a moon not the same
moon obviously that's impossible
honestly even look hard naked when I get
boned out I take my shirt off because
the bad feelings made me feel sweaty did
you know that the food you eat becomes
energy you know boom that's spaghetti
nachos
I found all three differences those are
two completely different pictures unless
he's in trouble there's only one man for
the job
Bert Macklin FBI thought I was dead so
did the president's enemies I'm gonna
tell you all of my secrets oh no that's
not necessary
I once forgot to brush my teeth for five
weeks I didn't actually sell my last car
I just forgot where I parked it I don't
know who Al Gore is and at this point
I'm too afraid to ask when they say 2%
milk I don't know what the other 98% is
when I was a baby my head was so big
scientists did experiments on me I once
threw beer is Swan and then it attacked
my niece Rebecca can't believe we're at
Hogwarts
no that's Buckingham Palace Hogwarts is
fictional do you know that it's
important to me that you know that Ron
and Diane sitting in a tree Kate s s is
s IPP I yeah Burt for the last time Ron
its princess rainbow sparkle was it
Putin Baltimore Putin attention
everybody
Madame's and miss was if you would do me
the obligation of having your honor
heretofore in the room docked right over
their heads what big event in that room
15 minutes Leslie this is a really cool
penis so far so good but in the words of
Jerry Maguire the human head weighs 8
pounds No hey Leslie who cares they're
old people they they sleep they complain
they watch family feud oh my god I want
to be an old person
[Music]
oh my god this maze is like amazing
so I thought to myself don't think Andi
act so you weren't thinking not at all
I cannot emphasize enough how little I
was thinking even have time to take a
shower before my wedding or after like
what we gonna have gases fill the volume
of whatever container they're in school
[Applause]
[Music]
you